so people who are joining this
livestream this is hopefully one of the
later meetings in our long series of
putting chemistry functionality into the
upcoming version often language and my
first question here is this is
presumably just a temporary thing this
has gone way very soon right so I wanted
to ask about that about that in the
second major point there whether
everything should be moved in the system
or only some of the function should be
moved in the system it's a broad project
it's got a lot every one of these
haven't we
some we might want to keep for
experimental for girls oh yeah no no we
can have as much as you want
experimental I'm sorry just you make
sure that there's no missile the stage
between system and system exit no I mean
I mean these should be in system
backtick I don't see any reason not to
put them there some of them might be
experimental there right okay yeah
though that definitely makes it easier
to to keep track of things on my end
time but there's nothing in this list
that we haven't well I haven't molecule
equal a molecule nearest and things we
haven't talked about those have we we
talked about molecule nearest but not
molecule equal Freight so we were
calling it same chemical q previously
it's one of the things I wanted to to
touch on with this okay
fine fine fine fine all right should I
start at the top yeah okay Freight so I
I couldn't fully articulate the reason
why I need a molecule q at the at the
last meeting essentially I mean it I
just need something is NaCl molecule Q
or not yes okay but it's not a molecule
is it right so it's a it's
something that it's a flag to tell me
that this is a valid Wolfram language
molecule and that I can use all of the
other functions that I've made on it
that's it it doesn't purport to actually
say whether it's good but that's not
going to cut it because you know NaCl
isn't a molecule but it's something in a
14 CL isn't probably anything but but
it's hopeless to base any q function
under the world
right I mean is Sonia sue I mean so so
maybe it shouldn't be a q-function okay
definition if if you come from is
supposed to give to falls it can only do
structural operations a coupon can never
make a non-trivial decision okay well
fine how would we reflect that in the
name because molecule Q you know really
sounds like it's actually talking about
the real world so yeah I don't know I
mean I feel like it's like mesh region Q
or graph Q it it it reflects the name of
its yes I understand I understand from a
structural point of view so how do we
reflect that in this name instead of
molecule Q maybe it's something like um
what's that well we don't really have
that I mean we have things like graph Q
but that the costings we built the
validity of this molecule of the
structural validity the symbolic
structural validity yes the molecule but
it has no statement about whether the
molecule will fall apart in ten to the
minus forty seconds great great I mean
it's purely says is this is this a
molecule object in the in the if we're
in an object oriented thing this would
be I mean like this we need this Steven
because that's what you need to do when
you write programs that accepts
molecules you gotta stand Roger but the
problem is that this is not asking is it
a molecule it is asking um it's okay I
think that that's okay as long as we
document it appropriately it doesn't
make any in
deeper statements about what exists
all right so we'd say has the symbolic
structure of a molecule suitable for
computation in our system yes
all right it doesn't bother you that
it's not a real world molecule Michael
does it bother you know the dolls that
reflects some bizarre epistemological
position you have yeah now I have to ask
other people um I think that there can
be something else that says but I think
that's gonna be relative to something
then you know in what sense is it real
is it the molecule the molecule is in
the word for language not the one who
could in the world right but then you
can ask various questions of what
real-world versions of this you know do
we have any Q functions that a real
world related like in G oh I don't I
don't think we have any now we have G Oh
within and it probably could be accurate
because then it would lie you know
well we have geo within Q sorry yeah but
I feel like that's but C it can't it
can't say it doesn't know right a QP
it's always a liar any q function to
hire yeah that's why I can only test are
two things which are unique right so
within Q is certainly that is a
structural test okay all right fine
molecule Q it is could you that's one I
wouldn't mind tagging is experimental
yeah absolutely okay all right what is
the point of these what are you asking
them so at the last meeting it was
suggested that a lot of these things
could be molecular instead of molecule
like molecular position molecular
pattern rather than molecule position
what the heck does molecule position
what does it mean what does this okay so
let's start off let me get a molecule
here let's see what molecule I even know
anything about okay so if I say caffeine
for example how do I get the molecule
representation of caffeine so you could
feed that entity to molecule or you
could feed the string caffeine to
molecule and it would translate it to a
Smiles could whoever's making background
noise please stop all right so now and
and so now if I wanted to get how do I
get the so if I say molecule plot of
this um I get that which is nice and now
if I say molecule plot 3d I'm sort of
warming up to what you're asking okay so
then I do that okay great dandy by the
way why is the bounding sphere still got
this weird why is it still got this
weird extra space around it
a virtual box right but the box isn't
there so it shouldn't have it it was
suggested that I investigate spherical
region goes to true but I have not
spiracle region to true won't work but
that the problem is the nothing special
here
you bought the same I think of this are
now to be plot I feel like that's the
issue of ethics we did not related to
any ok so can you guys communicate that
- Brad - please yeah see what he has to
say about it is it for Brett or is it
for you - it's more for users it's for
you - and we talked about this last time
here ok what is up and we say you know
in this case we can compute a bounding
region that's the minimum volume
bounding sphere
ok ok and that would be tight to the
content all right fine so we already
addressed this okay so now you you are
trying to talk about molecule Val but I
don't know who it landed with so I'm a
little bit and that's why we should have
a project manager here but anyway
whatever
uhm let's find out who is landed with
please yes go check okay how about you
feed that to you ask Sushma what project
manager this should go to yes I lik see
why don't you
okay why don't you tell me the answer
yes lay that to the project managers
okay but no no no tell me who is
supposed to be dealing with this when
you hear back from Lexi or whoever okay
okay now what is molecule values
supposed to do so molecule value is the
equivalent of identity values what I try
and make it so what's an example so if I
say molecular mass for example but now
if I simply say percent three molecular
mass that should work as well correct so
what's the so why isn't it I see so that
so it is well I kind of agree that
molecule value is okay what is molecule
position so if you want the index of all
the carbon atoms in percent three
molecule position percent three and then
just the string C should work why are
they in sub-lists because each cuz the
pattern that's the second argument could
be could be disconnected structures and
it could be a three so the substructure
pattern that you give there could be
more than one atom it could be a a bond
you know it underscored tell me that let
me see that let me see that so you say
double bond
whoever's typing in our ears please
don't do that so you should be able
a double bond I didn't cuz I didn't set
that one up if you put a comma between
those it will work okay that should work
okay so what does that mean that that
each pair of those four that's a
different return structure than position
Gibbs my position would give those will
be part numbers and those will be giving
the subparts so to speak right yes okay
so that is not great that this gives
something different so let's talk about
that for a minute
uh-huh what can we do with this so if I
wanted to get a subpart can I say
molecule part is there a um how do I get
out one of those sub parts molecule
extract so if I say comma six or comma
five there what does that do think you
need to wrap it in a list like why
that's wrong and that's been work either
okay so things so for instance in graph
we have the concept of index which are
just integers so let's take a look at
that for a graph okay so let's say all
right what's a nice graph to look at I'm
complete graph five
okay so now let's say I say subgraph
that comma wat the subgraph the vertices
that you want and they will bring in the
edges with it
that's the definition of subgraph okay
but but a part of what I wanted to say
so maybe we had this big discussion
about sort of annotations as a
replacement for properties yeah
you know the question is where how do
you say we're in a graph and it's it's
that's why I'm bringing this up for
molecule how do you say we're in a
molecule right and there two
possibilities it's like the annotation
position well no go ahead
so for graphs you know there's vertices
and there are edges and that's what we
use you know so when you say an edge
style is something you give the edge you
know with its two vertices connected
and you say what style it is right you
can search for it by saying patterns for
these things you know like the the
vertex position they can be pattern
variables let me try the sub graph here
if I say this so what would I do if I
wanted what would happen if I did that I
see so just okay so that's just a null
case so to speak but if I said um let's
say I said in here underscore question
mark even queue very nice so that's
probably yeah I mean if it was a bigger
graph I would see more stuff very nice
okay okay so now what's your point Roger
well I was thinking that if we if you
say that they're not positions and they
shouldn't be
they aren't positions their indices
right that that's that's my real point
and maybe that should inform ya what the
function is called right okay so what
does the molecule we might want other
things to like it seemed to me it would
be very natural to give the names like
c4 carbon you know find me all the car
actually this looks like it's the next
item in our list so let's just let's
just um deal with okay so you're saying
molecule Gras why isn't it just Gras I
don't understand a percent three would
give that graph so that is a that is a a
Plain Jane
gone right well so yes it's a it's a
great a system graph but it has vertex
example if I said something like what
would be a good example if it's a
trivial function in the sense that there
is no control that you want to apply to
that conversion and I think that that
could be just graph of it if on the
other hand you want to control right so
is that control and molecule curve not
yet but I was talking with Charles
earlier and saying that it might be
useful to offer a couple of levels one
when someone says molecule graph
they give a molecule and then given
another another argument to specify
whether what they want to inherit the
properties whether they wanted to just
be a simple graph with just with the
vertices in the edges just the
connectivity or to have it annotated
with all of the see if that makes sense
for us Bumi because death that indicates
intent and I think you've just started
in on this way of ways of mapping it to
graphs
yes well if that's important I don't you
know it could also be the case that you
say just gives me the completely
annotated thing and it's trivial to
strip the annotations in graph itself it
could be but it could also could be that
you want let's say that there are big
chains that you want to abstract to just
a single vertex you know so you provide
abstraction capabilities along the way
that might be very useful for some
structural operations so now this is a
case and this is something so that I
just did something crazy here I did a
graph union of this and that what the
heck did that do when you said
essentially like running canonical graph
on it well it creates the Union and then
it builds a new layout for it mix to one
well I understand that but I'm sure it
lost all the vertex annotation and I'm
asking why did that happen because it
didn't it that's what we're building for
12 - okay fine fine fine so in 12
what will this graph Union graph Union
thing it'll relay it out but will it
still have those vertices labeled what
if you specified that I mean it is
however it's specified it's specified
here right so now that gets into hold on
no I understand it hold on yeah yeah
okay there's thirty functions that takes
a graph produce an autograph I
understand there is a few of them that
are enery
like Union intersection and those are
the complicated cases okay
the basic option for propagation prop is
for annotation propagation annotation
propagation will support various options
like inherited yes
control it because it's not there is no
universal scheme for how to do this no
no I agree I agree tell me another golf
operation just for fun that I can apply
to this thing so you could find cycles
right or you want to graph an operation
that returns graph
well what would find cycles of of that
fine spanning tree well what is it
called fine cycles what is what is it
called what's the function wrath may be
grabbed cycles what's good know what
what is it called it's just fine cycle I
guess ok why is this in a sublist oh
because that's one cycle that can't be
one cycle so if there it must have found
the outer cycle rather than the
so-called argument can take specify how
many yeah what kind of other enumerators
we can specify golf line 19 line 21
right magnificent very nice
okay all right so the question here is
whether we need molecule graph or
whether we can simply say graph I
suspect we're gonna need molecule graph
is that also your friend Roger I think
that you want to control intent and I
think that there plenty of ways for us
to innovate and I for instance i I
suspect it's important to be able to
abstract away unnecessary sub graphs and
it's I think when you understand the
chemistry and not when you're sort of in
for example include hydrogen's or not
for instance for example molecule graph
presumably has an option include
hydrogen's to false true or not true if
it's not implemented yet it it should be
that's the intent for it to be but see I
can see I can see you know that that we
can abstract full you know carbon chains
and cycles to be sure hydrogen's no no
in this case include is correct because
they're literally not vertices in there
I don't think graph has an idea of
hiding vertices or maybe it does and
this is correct what it's doing here
okay all right I'm sold on this okay and
I'm sold on the rename here I'm real
good now let's talk about what these
part numbers actually boxes was usual
okay and is he actively doing something
on it or is it is it just flapping
Andrea we reported to that actually the
same day that he joined the meeting and
we talked with him but it just reported
I haven't done any follow up okay well
maybe you could find out what happened
to it um okay so let's talk about this
example of how you would use a molecule
position and extract or whatever we
renamed them to be here's a rather
reasonably complicated molecule and a
pattern for some atom that's bonded to
four different oxygens I have to say I
find all this functionality really
impressive I mean is that there's
anything else out there that does the
kinds of things you know as fluidly as
this it seems remarkably remarkably nice
anyway never mind that so I really feel
like the the symbolic pattern language
that we're adding here is something
that's above and beyond what's available
in any of the the toolkits that are that
are that people use in chemistry so they
all they all resort to using smiles and
smart strings which are very nice and
concise right but so some on our live
stream Bree brycie is some say
commenting with the challenge with
molecule indices is the established
nomenclature of certain core structures
such as steroids can you comment on that
oh he's talking about the different kind
of indices yeah do you know what they
are or we'll know so I mean I imagine
that's kind of a macro molecular motif
that's present in lots of different
types of larger molecules right okay no
no so when you when you name a chemical
you there's generally an agreed upon
position to start the numbering that's
what we're talking about I think what
we're talking about is sub molecules
that have names like the such-and-such
substance you know there's a bunch of
erisa students are used for searching
large databases of molecules
those are invariants you know if it's
gonna match that index is certainly
going to come out the same but even if
they come out the same they may not be
the same molecules all right this is
like a hash let's go back here to
molecule part or molecule extract what
is a molecule extract supposed to do
okay so is it is it roughly like a
subgraph yes although it's listable in
in the way that i've implemented it so
if you take the position of that
substructure that pattern you get a list
of list of indices and then when you run
I'm sorry molecule extract okay so let's
take some random molecule like this
molecule on line 24 it's a molecule
extract and so let's just say I say
range of 10 okay and so this will
extract just those atoms I don't even
know why why it necessarily is connected
here so generally let's see okay that
was a bug that was a bug you don't
support negative values if we're going
to do this we should support negative
values just like it does you know that's
what I was saying they're not positions
you thinking positions for lists and
trees yeah well that's why extract is a
weird name I mean what would be the what
what is the name of using a graph for
these kinds of things sub graph
okay and so what this would be is more
or less sub molecule but it may not be
anything like a molecule it may be um
fragments of something yes
I mean it's subgraph even though it
might be disconnected is but the thing
that came out there it it it types it's
like a molecule when you did range 10 I
know even if they were disconnected
still would because the the Wolfram
language molecule allows disconnected
structures as opposed to the technical
like I you pack definition of a molecule
I see ok so there we've got something
very randomized right so there we plot
that and so an important point here is
that when you there's a bunch of
vertices with no edges yeah but boy they
call h2o and things that's a good point
right so what's going on is the implicit
hydrogen's when you disconnect an oxygen
and you just have it floating there we
add two hydrogen's on to it and I've got
a clotting bug where I plot the implicit
hydrogen's different than the the ones
that are actually vertices of the of the
graph okay but I'm going to I will fix
that but but yeah so that's a point I
wanted to make is when you extract a
part of a molecule using this function
which I've called molecule extract I
want to return to you a valid molecule
and so I will add hydrogen's to fill
valence ease I think in the future we
will have something we call a molecule
fragment which is allowed to have
failing hairs let me okay that we're
gonna need that we could probably also
gonna need grow a fragment one day
comments from the Gulf Theory people
know how do you deal with has the graph
supports it directly
can't have an edge without vertices that
doesn't exist well but if you're doing
graph replacement you often want an edge
without vertices without a vertex at one
end because that's the whole point but
there's something else there it is kind
of like a pattern or something I mean no
I'm saying it yes you could think of it
as a blank there or you can think of it
as a hair which is you know a tentacle
fine border when we come to it well but
I'm but but my point is the definition
of graphs doesn't allow for dangling
edges it can certainly have isolated
vertices but graph cannot I understand
that I understand that's why I'm saying
just like Jason is talking about a
molecule fragment I'm saying you know
maybe there's a meaningful graph
fragment which is this thing with hairs
yes dangling but then that would be sort
of in application as sort of graph
patterns and graph replacement that
seems to me the only place that we've
heard of it yes I agree that's the only
place I've heard of it so then then it
doesn't sound general it sounds that
specific well but I think it's the same
thing we're talking about with molecules
it's the same application with molecules
it's you you can say replacement you can
say extraction of a pattern either way
anyway let's just for structuring this
meeting this is going to be a
complicated discussion with parts and
positions and so on I just want to look
ahead of what else you want to talk
about here and then we're going to try
and hit this one hard okay so this is
just the syntax for from molecule value
I so zoom we've touched on this a couple
of times like how to what this the
proper syntax would be forgetting the
formal charge of the the first three
atoms of a molecule well that's the same
thing what would keep on talking about I
mean if we had a way of representing
first three atoms then right so this is
why aren't you extracting the first
three atoms and then I see I see you
what you want to do here in this case
right you want a representation of a
symbolic representation of this molecule
it's like a mask on
and they're making sense that you only
want to consider the first three atoms
but you want the structure of that
molecule to be as it is but you only
want to consider the first three atoms
freight so we know that's like masking
in images for instance or if we were if
we were in a an object-oriented language
you could you could get the the atoms
and they they would have a pointer back
to their their parent molecule or
something but we don't have we that
would be a total mess how would that
possibly work no no I it wasn't three
separate atoms all with pointers what
would you possibly get anyway so let's
not that's not even worth talking about
it's a it's that's irrelevant there okay
what you're asking for here is something
closely related to what you're asking
for up here right because here you're
asking for a sub part of the molecule
which as we can see here can be a total
mess right so here you similarly are
asking for a sub part of the molecule
but here you're asking for the evaluated
sub part that might have fragmented the
molecule into lots of pieces here you're
merely saying this is the part of the
molecule I want to consider but I still
want to leave the molecule together but
for this property I want to look only at
those that part of the molecule is that
right yes so in a sense what this is
here you need something like you know
this is a super bad name but but
conceptually you need symbolic molecule
part correct phrasing soil would take
the it would have the molecule and the
the indices that's correct but but the
way you're doing the index extraction is
different from the way you've done you
know the index abstraction elsewhere so
that's not going to not gonna fly okay
so but that's what you conceptually need
there so but I it feels like it would be
nice if the sub value mechanism atom had
a manner for returning that so what I
have right there why why I mean why
aren't you trying why aren't you saying
what part of the molecule you care about
and then doing the sub value
okay so then you've meanwhile you've got
this so what the heck is this so that's
yet another way but let's look at it
let's look at it I think all the things
you're asking for are connected okay I
don't think these are separate things
that you're asking for and I personally
think that that molecule extract thing
is a total mess but could you please
somebody stop typing in just go on mute
to do that please
you
okay what did this do this is saying in
the Atem list
so Adam lists can take a pattern as the
second argument and in this case the
pattern why is that molecule value
you
why isn't this thing you've just created
a molecule value mechanism why isn't
that
what the heck is this going to do
you
I don't know what that does nothing I
don't understand this okay so it's meant
to be the analog of vertex list so
vertex list graph and then you can give
it a pattern to get back the list of
only those vertices that match the
pattern and so that's that's where it
was up until you see the rule and then
at that point it it felt like it would
be convenient to add some syntactic
sugars so that when they do the rule two
properties I go ahead and call molecule
value and give back only the ones so
yeah I get it I understand what you're
doing right I understand it doesn't seem
terrible but let's let me just get a
sense of where we're going here okay so
here so all of these things aren't
top-level functions at the moment I want
to have functions bond angle bond length
but I imagine it's going to require some
discussion with with Rogers group about
that's gonna have some overlap with
geometry bond angle is bond angle you
give it a molecule and a couple of atoms
is that correct three yeah three atoms
okay so so for example bond length is it
is it available here or do I have to go
to the sub yeah it's in that context so
chemistry Mac technology cool so is that
gonna work
no you have to it's a fully buried
context chemistry backtick molecule
geometry put the chemistry in that's a
good measure
okay so then line 24 and then for
example what happens if I just pick one
two three cuz you're asking for the
length at that point oh well why I mean
what if those aren't adjacent great so
so at that point it will just silently
give it to you and not complain Bob
actually wouldn't mind it I can
represent Bob on this matter he wouldn't
mind it if it did complain that they're
bonded because it says bond line
yeah I don't think that's right I mean I
think it's it's you know molecule
distance maybe what is molecule distance
matrix is that the distance matrices of
how far apart different atoms are yeah
so why isn't this bond length called
molecule distance and then it just tells
you the distance between two atoms
they're not if they're not bonded and
tough luck because because every chemist
knows the word the phrase bond length
it's something that gets thrown around
quite a bit and so the problem that you
have here is an entity in in molecule
value you don't have a mechanism to give
subsidiary parameters to the property
you're asking for which you need if
you're going to do something like bond
length right no so you can give you can
you can give attributes like in like an
entity value and give property
qualifiers I think that's what we call
them so so I can set bond angle up as a
molecule value and the further arguments
are are then fed into this buried
function right so modify molecule is the
top level function these are these sub
functions that it calls their strings
values molecule writes a modify molecule
mall and then type a string I just start
typing a string and it should tell you
if you should give options right so you
can add an atom it will add it
disconnected atom well what if I want to
add an atom at a particular position or
something particular I just add an atom
but what kind of atom well so it's going
to be disconnected is not tantalum or
what so you could put it you could put
any atom specification there you could
put atom C or you could wear so if I
just say what did that just do its name
data no that was the the null are PI I'm
sorry what are you talking about this it
added nothing so it's the same as if you
had put
an empty list is a third argument but
here if you put a list of CCC or just an
atom see it should add a code adding
multiple atoms yeah no no I so that's
not a valid atoms but you could give it
a list of valid atoms and it would add
them all okay okay so if I now say
molecule plot of this you'll have one
disconnected methane essentially why did
it hydrogen eight is that something in
the Plata or is that something in the
modified molecule it's a property of
molecule if you create a molecule just
an oxygen then it knows that oxygen
needs to be connected to two different
things and so it will add hydrogen's
it's common across I mean it's a common
but what's the issue is modified
molecule him
oh no issue I just those are not top
level functions I just wanted to point
them out those are all we haven't gone
really gone through that list of what
all those things do go at fine and again
here here well what the heck is that
right so these are descriptors in
computation and kim informatics you use
these things they they form a nice
numerical vector and people use them for
machine learning or
regression models and so what would be a
typical way of naming something like
that what is that what is that thing
called right I have not actually looked
up the paper on that one I've tried on
some of these two to rename them so okay
so why isn't this part of a net encoder
for molecules if that's what it is you
know that's definitely in the in the
works okay their way I see it there's
gonna need to be several net encoders
for molecule just cuz it's not it's not
as mature a field as vision there's
computer vision and machine learning
well there isn't one of there either
necessarily
but that's fine um okay so what are the
questions here I mean and this core
functions thing we're not discussing
that here is that correct
you've already been discussed its but is
there anything we need to discuss it I'm
trying to we have a limited time so I'm
trying to figure out what it is we
actually need to discuss no I think the
most important thing for us to discuss
is position and extract okay
so just with respect to these are the
naming issues here rates of the I some
of these names are far too ugly to to
document as exposed properties but they
are do have some activity Chi is that a
chi yeah so that should be spelled out
Zhi okay there are yeah it's a
descriptor that was put out in a
whatever it's fine but I mean we call it
connectivity CH I will be good um
then you've got the things like POA EVs
a which what is that I know the VSA
stands for van der Waals surface area
but I haven't I mean obviously what we
have to do with a bunch of these is to
consider just renaming them so that
they're actually descriptions rather
than just some weird acronym unless it's
unless it's such
what the heck um
this peoe ba does not seem to be the
world's most common issue common common
story um
okay well anyway alright fine you know I
mean these are perfectly reasonable
right and so those are defined as
functions in that file but then they get
exposed through molecule values so those
will all be mine okay I mean I think
it's kind of weird to do it that way but
if that's how you want do that's fine
here you see some of these indexes like
Hosoi high index there's a ton of them
right which could in principle be
applied to any graph is that not
correction yeah so what are we gonna do
are we going to have a sort of a special
function zoo of indices or what are we
gonna do with that oh no um cause you
have a comment on that it's really more
interesting when you do searching ok so
this these are things that you can't you
know so many things will map to the same
value particularly when they're discrete
values so you can't say that things are
equal if they have the same index or the
same value but you can reject there's
certainly no shortage on there like a
hash for these things like a hash right
but ok question for for graphs the
encoding of graphs that for net encoders
for neural nets and things what what is
uh what are we doing on that right now
nothing but I thought that the machine
learning team was doing something on
that then I don't know then you know
about it then you should report on that
ok but my question is from a design
point of view how do we imagine we're
gonna do it are we going to have I think
we should do it by having a named net
encoder and that's what I think we
should do for some of these I don't
think we should build it until we have a
reason to have it well we actually have
several reasons to try and do graphs
that's a separate issue ok but this has
to be the driver not just because you
can do it because we can do it ok ok ok
ok ok so I'm talking about the design of
these things right so the question is
does it happen do you get this to work
or is this a I think that this should at
least be documented as a net encoder for
chemicals right do you understand what
I'm saying Andrea you understand what
I'm saying
not really makes you not familiar with
this project so yeah so I I had an
intern here for the for the summer and
we we did some made some interesting a
couple of interesting neural nets and we
had to make the the encoder functions
just by ourselves and they're kind of a
little ugly I'm interested in cleaning
them up and making them the basic point
is that the basic point is in this list
of net encoders right should be
something for dealing with chemicals
right but notice how small it is I'm
surprised at how small this one is I
thought I thought we actually had a much
longer list of net encoders here um you
know so this one yeah yeah right I
understand okay so the point is that I
think we need to do projects to see what
they actually aiming you know what I
think that if I look at this function in
in source there are a lot more than a
few tries doubt yeah but then that
becomes a very hard thing to use right
let's say that they're worth hundred of
these net encoders oh sure yeah we're
more interested in one switch our
encoders for images image 3d etc what
I'm saying is you know I think there is
a default one for graphs which I think
we have used a couple of times and it's
probably something we should put in
there and I'm telling you that I don't
think you should have this if the main
purpose of this is to have it be a net
encoder put it in the net encoder system
not in here I'm making sense right so so
I actually am not totally certain what
that descriptor is used for ie fine fine
client but whatever it is that's a net
encoder you said you built in net
encoder for crops I'm encouraging you to
put it into the system
yeah in net encoder not as a property of
molecules to go what I'm saying
great okay so meanwhile you will report
back on what these are actually for yeah
right
um and a separate issue is Charles
trying to decide what to do with things
like the hosiah index and whether we
want to pull that up to a top level
function then
we looked at that because we were going
to do chemistry that's the way we looked
at it not for graphs itself okay
but that's the reason we looked at it
you can be down for graphs but would you
want to know I know that's the question
I don't really know you know just
because you can doesn't mean you're not
a ander Stan but I've given that we have
the code to do this for a graph it
wouldn't know we shouldn't collude with
things that you just can do now I
understand so there's a question of how
we package it right I mean yes there are
a bunch of indices and I know I mean I
don't know what what's this is something
a weiner something or other indexed as I
recall that's relevant for graphs of
chemicals that tells you about boiling
points am I remembering correctly right
we have that in yeah this one that
relates to boiling point so why isn't
that here I mean they're kind of like
wait wait Jason why isn't that here
right so that isn't one of the ones that
came built-in for the so I haven't I
haven't I haven't brought it over from
my out from the alpha code yet okay so
there's a bunch of others that we could
potentially put put in here right so a
bunch of these indexes I mean I'm sure
you've seen this too are sort of weak
predictor of yeah I know these physical
properties yes you wanted to focus on
molecule getting to me basic
functionality yeah I know I know I'm
trying to I'm trying to define how the
project should develop because we're
thinking about it today I'm not saying
this has to be in there for the first
release am I making sense yes yeah all
right so let's go back here to the main
question that you've raised which is how
to deal with
extracting elements and molecules and
specifying them so say I've got a I have
a pattern where is that pattern in a
molecule and how should we in what way
can we understand I understand it and so
so what you've got in a molecule every
atom has an index correct yes okay so
when you ask where is a subgraph in a
graph the answer that you get is a list
of indices correct that's elastic
vertices no no no no no no indices it's
not the what do you got the names of the
vertices or the indices of the vertices
child dynamo da vertices the names okay
so in the case of molecule we also have
the possibility of naming vertices
correct but we have nothing that forces
uniqueness of names of vertices is that
correct or is that not correct let's see
so so a user can give a name to an atom
and it definitely it needs to be unique
okay fine fine so it's the same as with
a graph where the indices could be
successive integers or they could be
specific names is that correct
but we've never implemented anything of
giving a name to an atom that wasn't
named by the user so one could imagine
I'm talking about that I understand what
you're saying but I wasn't talking about
that trying to understand just like in
graphs the names of atoms can either be
successive integers or they can be
whatever you happen to give the name
that atom as a name correct yes okay all
right so now what we're asking is a
canonical
structure I assume it's the same in
molecule because it's built so close on
graph is that there is a canonical index
set behind it always
whatever you give it if you call them
foo bark knew you know there's still
index one two three behind it yes okay
that that's true too but well I don't
actually yeah okay fine you can say that
but I mean you could say one two three
fubar and then you're saying foo is
implicitly index four is that correct
yes okay fine all right so now a sub
molecule in your definition
is it specified but I'm sorry it's
finding a pattern right finding a
functional group finding something like
that no it's specified by a collection
of atom identifiers correct yes
connected to each other no no it's not
specified by that let's be clear is it
or is it not specified by a collection
of atom identifiers no Jason wait I mean
that's how I think of it I mean so so
that like that that so4 group there is
is specified by that the molecule and
those the five indices that they make it
up that alright so for a subgraph the
way you're specifying a subgraph in
graphs the sole way to specify a sub
graph is by a list of indices correct
charles are that correct or the list of
n edges because it induces the the graph
structure I think for molecule pattern
that is more the sub cardi used to
actually describe departing you're
looking for sorry I didn't understand
that so in the case of sub graphs you're
saying like you can give address Stephen
registers you can say the lore of the
form you know to arrow three and things
yes right okay and you can see which
type of vertex is you have right yes see
if a double bond forgot no wait wait
wait wait wait in a graph what do you
mean by you can give the type of
vertices well I was thinking patterns to
identify you know let's say that you've
used your own naming convention than you
wanna write as the names are expressions
and explained match with patterns
exactly exactly
okay fine
okay so but my point was that for
molecule day you know she look at the
molecule pattern is more hopefully a sub
cough which really is stratifications
um okay sorry I would say what you said
again I said the molecule pattern is
coffee speaking a subgraph they used to
identify that pattern in the molecule
just such a molecule right but
unfortunately this thing here so if we
were to say that this is a molecule here
forget the blank
and call that a molecule right no I
don't understand what that's doing
why is molecule so I get so that's a bad
message but you have the number five in
your list of bonds and so that's why
that's a bad message yeah I agree
okay
what
yes not to write it sir I'll look at I'm
looking what's not defined what is this
no ok so it's an even worse message than
I thought so in a molecule you have to
say what kind of bonds they are let's go
to these these are bonds phrasal bonds
right so I made up the the bond head to
represent an unspecified bond that's not
gonna cut it it's not gonna cut it
that's so that's yet another pattern
construct is that correct yes what is
the list of pattern constructs so so
there's molecule pattern bond and so the
only other thing that is purely pattern
would be smarts pattern but that is so
that I was there was one of the bullet
points I wanted to hit on was we make we
mayn't might not need smarts pattern
either you construct something with
parts or you can give it something like
it's Maspeth and so a more like a
generic one that's why we wanted to
bundle this all together into molecule
better.i this just doesn't make any
sense to me there's a different ways to
classify that what you want to extract
look ok so you can have an atom that's a
pattern you can have a bond whose
characteristics are patterns that true
what other things can you pattern eyes
no that's that's also support a string
smarts string is not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about if you're trying
to match a subgraph what things in the
sub graph can be personified so it could
be blonde who could be single bond it
could be double bond it could be triple
bond it could be aromatic blonde was a
different one should be sure I
understand that but I'm asking what
things so this is a sub graph right it
attaches with hairs to the rest of the
molecule correct yes yeah ok
how are those hairs specified here
they're not well okay why is that I mean
in other words if I said well I want
this but I want it to connect only with
double bonds to the rest of the molecule
how would I specify that right so so the
ends of the hairs would then need to be
blanks would need to be vertices in the
subgraph okay so normally when you say
this is a subgraph you're saying it's it
is certain parts of the molecule and
you're silent on what other bonds exist
these are bonds that exist that you are
requiring to exist but there are other
bonds that connect to these oxygens and
you're silent on what those are is that
correction yes okay so the difference of
this with a subgraph is what in a
subgraph you said you can specify
vertices and here we seem to be
specifying edges as well but how do you
specify edges in the standard sub graph
we're set up no this I mean I believe
from what I see what actually drew here
is a sub graph isomorphism it's not
really sub graph that u sub graph
isomorphism you have a curve you have a
sub graph you want to find the
corresponding sub graph which has more
feet to that curve exactly and then and
then here we take the extra step of
making sure that that isomorphism Maps
cross this the properties that we've
specified need to match like I said the
four party name I'm sorry what
properties well so in this case the so
the four of the specified vertices need
to have the atomic number equal to eight
the edges we're not putting any any type
of I'm sorry I thought what we were
talking about here so this is a five is
the pattern that involves five atoms
right it's a sub graph involving five
atoms yes okay and what I'm asking about
graphs is when you specify sub graph you
can give the vertices that are involved
in the sub graph by name
this is specifying them by type but in
the in the other case it's by name right
and then you're saying Charles that you
can also give the edges
in some way is that correct yes okay now
do you also have a way of specifying by
annotations or what you're currently
calling properties because this is
effectively saying for uh vertices have
the property that their atom type is
oxygen
yes but no not yet
okay so you can imagine a moment when
you can do sub graph isomorphism with
respect to saying I want all the black
vertices that are connected in this way
for example right yes do you have a
design for how to do that yes what is it
roughly and it's essentially was a an
option to specified which property do
you want to preserve to paint the
computation of no no that's not right
Charles that's not what we're talking no
I think Stephen is talking about is to
identify what parts to pick out exactly
so let's say you've got a graph and it's
gone and taking into account not just a
connectivity not just a pure graph but
there's two things right there is the
structure on the property I thought it
was talking about the property yeah all
right let me give you an example we've
got a graph it's its vertices a colored
red green or blue okay so what I want is
a little Pentagon that is all green
vertices I don't care what the numbers
of the vertices are I just want a
Pentagon that's all green vertices am I
making sense right how would I specify
that well actually now you you can
actually do that by doing the pattern
right so you can do the pattern and then
you acts in the pattern you know
condition you know property value or a
notation value now okay so that's that's
a somewhat more okay so an alternative
would be to say something like the
analog of this would be to say something
in the graph like annotation using the
new terminology blah blah blah blah blah
blah there now I don't even know you
know there's a question about the
flatness of annotation that is if you
give one annotation here even if a
vertex had three annotations with this
one annotation then still match
you get what I'm saying a vertex has
three annotations it's red it's
triangular and it's got weight 17 okay
I'm simply saying I want a cluster of
red vertices so I need a way of
specifying of giving a pattern in this
graph pattern that says make sure that
vertex is red but ignore whether it's
weight is is anything I'm making sense
yes okay so is there a way to do this
what is just just what Charles said it's
a bit clumsy I think that one could make
could probably enlarge to pattern
language yeah I get it
okay well to use an answer right now
it's sort of relying on the actual
pattern language which makes it very
powerful yes I understand
okay but so the analog of that in the
chemistry case would be a slash
semicolon
you know a test that involves are you
the atom that I'm looking for type thing
no no no that's not what we have here
right that's not what this pattern is
this pattern says look at these
particular atoms right
yeah you're not the thing you just asked
for is not provided for by this baton
language
okay did you see that I mean Jason do
you agree
no words I want a tantalum atom that is
surrounded by I don't know scan diems or
something I have no idea if that binds
in any way but but you know what I'm
saying you don't have a way to specify
that with this pattern language no not
without let's see
so hydrogen's are treated special there
is something in the language you could
wrap one of those vertices and specify
it's hydrogen count you'd specify its
neighbor count but you can't specify
what those name bar
so you would wrap that capital o in an
atom and then you could write hydrogen
at count goes to the three okay okay
fine all right okay to be more specific
the the tantalum would have to be part
of the pattern okay so let's go back
again to what we're talking about we've
got this way of specifying essentially a
sub molecule here okay just like we have
a way of specifying a subgraph but
neither is really as as expressive as it
should be
because in the case of the subgraph well
this question about what's around me
is not specifying specifiable in a
subgraph case either is it in other
words it is that it's clumsy okay I
understand but but so okay so the two
issues there one is what are my
annotations and the other is what is my
context is that right and in terms of
the what is my context the problem with
the subgraph specification right now is
and it's the same problems with these
hairs and graph fragments and so on is
is the vertex in or out when you say you
know extract is the vertex you know is
it coming with the sub graph or get it
merely for context yeah right okay so
let's go back again to what we're
talking about here okay so what you want
so first point is this molecule pattern
mechanism right so you're referencing so
you might want to reference things by
their index by index or by their type or
by their properties correct yeah I mean
um so you reference them by their index
in the in the list of bonds right yes
where am i storing this because I'm
about to make notes which I don't want
to get lost
I've web been storing these in a
particular place yeah last time you
specifically said I'll email you this
but I'm not keeping it so that worked no
Jason
the record of meeting squares okay so
reference atoms by index or by the type
of other properties okay so now
similarly I'm gonna write down nominally
growth pattern okay
and here we reference
okay Adams okay so we reference vertices
by index actually or their name here
index / name index or name
you
or potentially or by their annotations
right it's that right
yes yes okay so now the next thing we
might want to do is okay so you've got
the edges which are being referenced in
a certain way but we also potentially
want to reference atoms by their context
that makes sense but I don't quite
understand how we would do that did you
get what I'm saying it's a little bit
the same as if we had in our pattern
language it would match something but we
give context well actually we do that
right now because what we can do in our
pattern language is we say X : you know
let's say we do this we could say give
me you know something like this right
where the thing matches that whole
structure but I'm just returning the X
thing yeah like in cases for example yes
right so that is something that I could
do for from out I mean it would be I
could code that up and I know how it
could be done so fine so that's so this
is the way that you and the same thing
could be done for a graph and principle
right
so in a sense when you say subgraph
right now you're saying if I'm
understanding correctly you are giving
well the thing is that is guaranteed to
return a graph a subgraph returns a
graph so I think it needs to be
something there's no when you yeah when
you extract I mean what is so I'm not
sure what you writing here because what
what was saying here the sub graph is a
graph so I get it I get it I get it but
I mean that the point here whoo okay
let's keep going here so now you're
talking about the bonds the edges right
okay so you reference atom you reference
edges well basically bonds here by their
vertices or by their type what else
I haven't hooked it up yet but we could
you could add patterns on the properties
into the pattern so so we can we have
all their properties right okay so now
what do we want to return here which
what we're trying to so again when you
say properties you mean what we know
also call annotations right
you don't mean not a property well so I
mean computed properties so and I think
that that's a distinction that would be
need to be made as properties that are
so we AG bond lengths bond less than you
know five angstroms long exactly yeah
Jason I really wish you could find a way
to not be as noisy but anyway but but
Tim
okay
so
this is very different so in the case of
graphs again you can reference edges
by their vertices is that correct
is that correct yes yes yes but but I
mean we have an edge object right so
they use edge in patterns and O's I see
so you say edge we don't know well
directed edge in undirected edge okay so
that's an interesting case because like
bonds right where there's single bond
double bond and so on you have
undirected edge and directed edge by
making sense and I don't think you have
a generic for saying an edge of any kind
do you know right so that will be the
analog of the single bond double bond a
bond of any kind
right yeah right you simply don't have
that right right in this case it seemed
I mean you could use or you know
alternative yeah yeah yeah right right
so the pattern language accounts for
that but you could also perfectly well
say this which is an undirected edge
right so you could also have directed
edges right we take the polarization to
account one polarization for what for
these that what those are no it's not
before sort or something
frayed I mean we don't have a concept of
a directed bond said no but this Pope
uses a polarization right because in
this case you would give it a direction
yeah okay fine but we don't have that
notion yet but but we certainly this
could perfectly well represent a a bond
of any type no not necessarily because
we're trying to invent something but we
don't have to bring in a whole thing
called bond to just represent the simple
pattern thing single bond vertical bar
double bond right I mean these like
avoid doing that for me to just parse
rule in that way by the way either way
it doesn't matter rule undirected rule
you know two-way rule whatever okay
thank you but but but but that's not
solving the whole problem okay so the
thing that you get back by okay so first
point is how do you reference a sub
molecule here right second point is how
do you return the sub molecule or
possibly represent the sub molecule
without returning it so you can ask
about its other properties am I making
sense okay so hold on we need the notion
of a sub molecule and there are two
cases return the sub molecule and
consider the some molecule in situ I'm
making sense
because that case there is when you want
to find out I don't know something about
I don't know what what was the thing you
were computing before I can't remember
what it was
one two three thing where you was asking
for some kind of um so the the gas tank
of partial charges yeah yes of course
okay so that's the case there so one
case is you return the sub molecule for
further processing and the other is you
consider it in situ now how common is it
and the model in situ reminds me of
highlight you know highlight does yes
yes it does um so we've before me I mean
you can look forward for for Smart's
pattern to daylight and you could see
what kind of pattern we want to support
right and they are much much more than
the current list here
about your point I'm sorry I don't
understand you know if you go to look
for smarts pat-down do a quick search
for that and then click on the delete
link you will see what kind of since we
want to support you well actually I mean
the smarts pattern language has a lot of
stuff that I don't know that what are
you talking about I mean you're
basically the point that you're making
is what that there are things that are
involved context that we're not
describing here yes okay here's a link
for smarts patterns so these are the
things we should support okay but
there's a way that we could just give
this string for a smart pattern correct
yeah but but take a look at what these
things are they involve things like he's
very non-local you know anticlockwise
presumably but in most implementations
of this those things even the non-local
ones are condensed down to be local so
so the chirality represents the
three-dimensional arrangement of five
atoms but what they do is they make that
a property of the central atom and they
do this pattern matching based on that
is that an implementation hack or is
that something relevant to users who are
specifying the pattern no no so that
that's an implementation detail okay so
fine so we don't care about that the
important point is how do we specify the
patterns
right and is it the case that one of
these smarts patterns you know how do we
think about that graph theoretically
what is one of these smarts patterns
is it a molecule graph that has had
certain molecules replaced by blanks
what is it
yes you can substitute for the rest is
that sufficient or is that only part of
what you need to do and also what comes
out what's the return for these smarts
you know that you were referring to
Buren but do you get the full molecule
back that matches that or do you get a
part of it or what happens so in this
case you would dress you would
substitute by all right because the rest
or something but you can simplify the
rest so what you want to do before nano
we are active centers on the molecule
just what we care about right so knowing
where the pattern exists in the molecule
and also does the pattern exist
okay so does it exist does it match okay
that's for lookup okay then the second
thing is is where which is to me like
highlight yes little position like a
position like thing okay yeah okay what
other
things are them or well so you can do
replacements so you have a pattern I
have this other pattern and I wanted a
replacement that's how we do that's how
you could hack a reaction okay have you
got that functionality in yet yeah it's
in modify molecule no I know that but so
okay so modify molecule is the thing
where you have to give it a description
of where in the molecule it's like
replaced by you have to say where you
want that replacement to happen is that
correct
so I envision there being a replaced
part and a replace although I may have
implemented them in the same function so
if you go to core functions and there's
a section for unmodified molecule and I
believe I have an example for the
replacement so the last section there so
there should be a replace in a replace
list replacing abstract not relevant
that one of them is replaced no one of
them is replaced by look one of them is
you know replace a thing that looks like
this a pattern that looks like this and
this is replace these identified parts
correct yes now notice that in replace
part each identified part is
independently replaced by something
you get what I'm saying yeah unlike in
replace part this replaces all the parts
together yeah see what I'm saying
yes
okay so let's loop back again to the
question when you are specifying a piece
of a molecule the way you're doing that
right now is by giving these lists of
item indices correct yes
okay what if what I had said in the
molecule position was I want bonds from
here to there what would you give us the
result would you give the atoms that are
at the ends of those bonds or what would
you give so let's so it would be any
bonds that are connected within those
right and so it would be single bond 8 7
comma double bond 9 10 I'll tell them
this so you would not be giving so this
is a naked list of indices so you will
be giving a quite different structure
which is the structure that involves
bonds correct yeah because the analog of
that will be a list of atoms here and
I've implemented those in bond lists and
atom list so if you give bond list but
but it's it's kind of different because
bond lists the pattern that you give
needs to match a single bond only
whereas in molecule position the pattern
you give could be a whole substructure
yeah all right let's let's I mean we
should wrap up here because really late
for the next thing um
well we always have got to come back
around on this um
so should we meet sooner yeah very soon
very soon
I mean I'm such a pushover for the tech
conference has nothing to do with this
there has nothing to do with this what
we care about is the freeze date yeah
yes this and we have some other things
which we have to talk about what else I
thought this was an agenda I thought
that did not have a complete agenda here
my streams of the molecule convert yeah
I was singing the local identify that we
came up with and on the email thread but
I was thinking we could wait until after
we've yes substructure which is also
very common singing functionality
chemist bond so I I think that we
covered that pretty reasonably last time
I mean it's it's a it's a small function
molecule intersection or something like
that because maximum substructures it's
a very mouthy for foreign language well
it's not the right thing if it's only
about molecules molecules well I'm sorry
okay so then so then why don't we have
something
I mean I would have thought we'd end up
with something like molecule what does
it return anyway it's another one of
these sub molecules isn't it but it's
trying to return but it returns a
pattern a pattern as a string pattern
actually it what what not a string
pattern I'm a smarts pattern so I'm a
pattern that is a string I'm sorry
whoops but and how does that relate to
the sub molecules we've been talking
about what you do a maximum common sub
structure of two different molecules and
it returns back a at the moment I'm
smarts pattern but it could also return
a molecule pattern okay so hold on hold
on so this is so this is an example of
something so maximum max common sub
structure right yeah here's an example
of a function which should return should
return a sub molecule return either a
sub molecule
I shouldn't return a pattern because a
pattern is something that kind of well I
guess it could return the Dyson yeah
okay I think the advantage the possible
advantage of a pattern is that you can
then highlight just look at that in
context in either of the molecules right
yeah and that's that's what we do an
alpha right now yeah I mean the plotting
the two molecules with the substructure
highlighted I see so if I give two
random molecules and alpha well it will
I see that if I give molecules so if I
say give me two molecules that have some
common sub structure caffeine and
benzene I haven't the slightest idea
you
why is what is it taking all that time
for what is it doing
okay there's no okay well I give me an
example which has one Oh common sub
structure diagram maximum common sub
structure there you go
show substructure locations
all right yes it's what J is implemented
what's all okay that's pretty nice
because this what the origin you very
started from - have you wanted that yeah
I started wanting to do all these things
in alpha and got tired of using an
external library to do it and we wanted
to be able to do it in the language this
is what became us truly one so this is
let's be clear on what they really want
so they want to be able to make pictures
or do they want to be able to compute
with this computer visit just so-so but
but but so dirty pictures is important
as well each of each of those hold on
each of those things
pattern looks like a mask you know
restrict your computation to that in
context typing I would think so
right which is the case of a sub
molecule as we've said here until Oh
consider the sub molecule in situ yeah
I'm unconvinced about this return the
sub molecule thing and I think that's
potentially I mean what it could do is
is you know not a way to think about it
is that it contains the annotations
where there those things that have
special meaning that computation can
then you know so it comes as it's it's a
molecule that then has been quotes
masked or highlighted or annotated or
annotated right okay and one could have
probably workflows that then do decent
things with that from there on out cuz
then you don't have to yes so there I
mean that would require so a new head
that is like no you require an
annotation that standard that's being
actually used by a lot of compute
functions right
I mean like masking analogous to masking
in image processing which does except
except it's not in the image so dare you
have to tag it along all the time yeah
right Furler is here the annotation will
be in the molecule yes good so we're
essentially talking like it like
highlight graph which highlights best
for me right but but but it's not store
highlight graph doesn't store sort of a
separate property called highlight
actually does we do right actually it's
a good point I didn't think of that yes
we did eventually so but visually I
don't think most people see that choice
I think you and I do but it's let's just
see the visual visual representation of
it and I don't think computation takes
care take that into account anywhere at
this point right okay these are fairly
big loose ends
actually okay it's quite complicated I
think we don't get it wrong about what
yeah I actually didn't what so to be
honest molecule similarity I think is is
such a big topic for us to talk about
that I don't even know that we'll have
the time to really nail it out before
release so those functions might just
stay I mean I have said let's get
scheduled
let's get scheduled for sometime the
next two days to continue this yeah and
this is I can send you this notebook
here best term but this is also in a
chemical structure subfolder of ILD okay
okay great for people on the live stream
we are going to another meeting that
will be live-streamed in just a moment